welcome back
i hope you had a good thanksgiving
and uh are all refreshed
and ready uh to
uh
uh think about some theory of
computation um we're in the home stretch
now this is uh we have this lecture and
two more to go and um
so today i have for you um
[Music]
a
completion of the
theorem we started before the break
um
where we had a uh
we where we introduced probabilistic
computation
and we uh talked about
the class bpp as i hope you remember
and we looked in particular at these um
these problems involving branching
programs
where we
started the proof that the
problem of equivalence of two read once
branching programs can be solved in this
class bpp so what i'm going to do is
spend the first
15 minutes or so just reviewing where we
were
because we started this um it feels like
a long time ago now
and i just want to make sure that you're
all uh
um
uh on the same page and we're all uh
um remembering what we were doing and
then i will finish off the proof
and
along
with doing that we're going to introduce
an important method um
well we started that we we looked at the
method of arithmetization last time so
we will review that
we're going to use that again in the uh
the
work that we're going to start on
thursday on interactive proof systems so
this is a kind of in some ways both a an
interesting theorem in its own right and
a warm up for what we're going to be
doing um on um
in the last topic
of the of the semester
um
okay um
so um
uh let's just
remember what we were doing so we
introduced probabilistic turing machines
um
so those are these machines that have
they're a kind of non-deterministic
machine but there's a different rule for
acceptance
and
these are also non-deterministic
machines which can either make
one choice
just to have a deterministic uh move at
a step or they can make two choices
um and when the machine makes two
choices we actually think of there being
a probability there um where the machine
is tossing a coin to decide which branch
to go on
um
so with that there is a
uh tree of possible branches
and the probability of some particular
branch is going to be one over two to
the number of coin tosses on that branch
um
and so
[Music]
we then use that to define the
probability that the machine accepts
um which is the sum over all of the
probabilities of the accepting branches
and the probability that it rejects is
one minus the probability that it
accepts
um
so you know thinking about it um
uh you know
this
captures the idea that if you just run
the machine
on a random
set of inputs
um
from the coin tosses
what the probability that you're going
to end up with the machine accepting
that's the probability of acceptance um
defined in that way
now if we're thinking about the machine
deciding some particular language
it's supposed to accept the strings in
the language and reject the strings
which are not in the language but
because of the probabilistic nature of
the machine it might get the wrong
answer on some branches
and so
we say that a machine decides a language
with a certain error probability means
that the probability of getting the
wrong answer is going to be at most that
error probability epsilon over all of
the possible inputs to the machine
so if we say that the machine is error
probability one-third that means that it
gets the right answer for every every
string with probability at least
two-thirds
um
[Music]
okay so
that led us to the definition of this
complexity class bpp
which i don't remember if i told you
what it stands for it's bounded
probabilistic polynomial time that's
what bpp stands for
and it is
the bounded means is bounded away from
one half
because we don't want to allow the
machine to have probability one-half um
because then um
bad things happen uh the machine can
just toss a coin when it decides to make
um
uh an answer and not really give us any
information
um
[Music]
then
we also uh went over
the amplification level we did not give
the proof but we went over the statement
of the theorem the proof is really just
a calculation
that you can
drive down that error probability to
something extremely tiny um
just by basically rep repeating the
machine and taking the majority vote of
what it does on several different runs
if you run the machine 100 times
and you see if it's mostly accepting
then you're going to accept and the
chances that the machine was really
uh biased toward rejecting even though
your in your samples see mostly
acceptance is extremely small and you
can calculate that but you can make that
very tiny so small that for all
practical purposes it's really giving
you the right answer um but you know
it's not deterministic so it's not quite
100
guaranteed
um
[Music]
and the way i like to think about um
bpp
in a uh in terms of the computation tree
of the machine um
so that when it's accepting
most of the branches are accepting
you know weighted by their probability
of course but most of the branches so
the there are many accepting branches
when you're accepting and many rejecting
branches when you're rejecting
so just another way of saying the same
thing
um now
we're gonna start right jump right in
with a check-in um and this is a little
bit more
not exactly the material of the course
but um a little bit more on the
philosophical side but let's just see
how you do with it um
when you're actually running
a probabilistic machine
you imagine the machine as we're as
we're kind of informally describing it
it's called tossing coins
um
every time it has a non-deterministic uh
every time it has a
a choice
so a choice tosses a coin to decide
which way to go of course
you know a real computer does not have a
coin to toss presumably well maybe you
might actually build
some hardware into the machine that lets
it access randomness in some sense you
know maybe it uses um some
quantum mechanical effect you know to
get some random value or maybe it uses
the timer i you know i'm not exactly
sure you know you can imagine having a
bunch of ways of implementing that
a typical way that people implement
randomness randomness
in an algorithm is to use a
pseudo-random number generator
which is a procedure that might give you
some kind of a value that looks random
but
may not actually be random
it's for example giving you
the digits of pi
if you express if you want binary
expressing pi as a binary
as a binary number
then you might calculate the different
successive digits of pi and use that as
for your random number generator um of
course that's a deterministic procedure
so it's not really random um
and but you know often people do use
those kinds of things when they're
simulating
random machines so what do you think
about doing that
could we use a random uh pseudorandom
generator
as the source of randomness for a
randomized algorithm um
what
yes or no or what do you think
um
so let's launch a poll on that
and see what your
opinion about using pseudorandom number
generators instead of truly random true
randomness for our algorithms
i'll give you a few seconds a
minute to
weigh in on that
okay
we're gonna close this down everybody's
participated who wants to uh one two
three
um
[Music]
okay
yeah i think probably the the best
answer is a
um let's take a look at some there are a
couple of answers here that
really that don't make um that aren't as
good i would say uh b
well you know usually people think of
random pseudorandom generators as pretty
fast procedures um they're not not that
interesting otherwise so
um i wouldn't say that b is a good
choice because
you know they're they're usually pretty
quick to implement
um
[Music]
c is
a worse choice even
because uh turing machines can do
anything that any other algorithm can do
so certainly if there is such a thing as
a pseudorandom number generator and
there is then you could uh implement it
on a touring machine um
d is kind of an interesting answer uh
because you're saying well that would
imply that p equals bpp if you could
actually simulate
uh randomness with a deterministic
procedure
um
but in fact the reason i i would
not choose d is because it's perfectly
conceivable that p
does equal bpp we don't know that p is
different from bpp so it's conceivable
that they're equal
and in fact i think if you if you polled
most complexity theorists
they would
most most people in my field would would
believe that p does equal bpp
just for this very reason
that if you had sufficiently good
pseudo-random number generators
you could actually eliminate the
probabilism in these probabilistic
computations you could just run them on
the pseudorandom number generator and in
fact there is some theory around that um
that has been developed um
but at the present time we do not know
how to prove that there are pseudorandom
gen number generators and it has some
actually there's actually in some line
of this research has some connection
with the p versus np problem but we
don't know how to prove that there are
sufficiently good pseudo-random number
generators that would would allow you to
run them on a probabilistic algorithm
and have a guaranteed behavior which is
as good as running truly random numbers
into the um
probabilistic
algorithm and so
the the answer that i would pick would
be a that you could use it sure you
might get the right answer but it's not
guaranteed we just don't know how to do
the analysis for the pseudorandom number
generators and you know if you had such
you had ones that were good enough they
would show p is equal to vpp
but that might be in fact the correct um
that might actually be true
okay
so let's continue on um
and uh
remember now branching programs you know
we had these uh kind of networks um of
nodes and edges
um and there was a procedure you know
we'll see a couple of examples again
some of the ones that we had from before
uh where you um
you know you have branching programs
look like this
and you know you you have a bunch of
query nodes you look at the settings of
the variables to decide whether to go
down a zero edge or a one edge and
eventually you're going to end up at an
output node and that's going to be the
output of the branching program and in
such a way these branching programs
define boolean functions
from the settings of the input variables
to a 001 output
now you might have two branching
programs and wonder whether they're
computing the same boolean function or
not and testing that is a co np complete
problem as you are asked to show on your
homework um
uh
now
if the branching program however has a
restriction namely that it's
not allowed to ask to query the same
variable more than once on a path
then
with that restriction you can
we call it a read once branching program
and then the situation for testing
equivalence seems to be different um in
fact we can give a bpp algorithm for
testing the equivalence of read once
branching programs even though such a
thing is unlikely to be the case for
general branching programs because of
the co-np completeness
okay so i hope you're comfortable and
with me on all that reasoning
um
okay
um
[Music]
let's uh
so
um
[Music]
all right so the idea for proving this
is what we're going to do is we're going
to take the two branching programs and
run them on a randomly selected input
but as we observed last time if you just
run them on a randomly randomly selected
boolean input where we assign the
variables zeros and ones
then that doesn't give you the right
answer with high probability
because the two branching programs
might be
different computing different boolean
functions but they differ only on a
single input setting
and then
just picking them at random you're not
going to have a very high probability of
finding that one place of difference
so instead what we're going to do
is define a way to run these branching
programs on non-boolean inputs where the
variables are set to values other than 0
and 1.
2 3 7 22
and make sense of that
and then argue that by running the two
branching programs on a randomly
selected non-boolean input
that that's very high probability of
giving you the right answer
um
so somehow by expanding the domain of
possibilities you're going to uh better
your chance of getting the right answer
very significantly
okay so even though these two branching
programs might agree on all of the
on almost all of the boolean
inputs
we're going to show that by
doing this arithmetization
so this is the method um
uh
they're going to if they're really not
equivalent they're going to differ
almost all of the time on the expanded
domain
okay now we have to prove
so that there is uh um
you know that's where today's work is
going to be
okay
so um
why don't we just stop
and
make sure we're all
together on this
i can take any questions um
i'll also review how the arithmetization
goes
but that i'll do that next
so are we all okay
on this
um
good so let's move on
so in order to move toward understanding
what it means to run the branching
programs on these non-boolean values
we're going to have to uh
uh get a somewhat different perspective
on the computation of a branching
program
so the standard com perspective is that
you know you um
you take your setting your assignment to
the input which is
0 1 1 for x1 x2 and x3
and use that to follow an execution path
through the machine
so you know x1 is 0 x2 is 1 x3 is one
the output is one
okay as i've indicated in yellow
um
this other perspective says well let's
let's we're gonna by operate by labeling
the nodes and edges of the machine
and
that's going to have a very direct
correspondence with the execution path
perspective so we're going to label all
the nodes and edges on the path with a 1
as indicated in yellow
and all the nodes and edges that are not
on the path all the other nodes and
edges are going to be labeled zero
okay
so by following the ones
it's like the breadcrumbs you know and
hansel and gretel these are the this is
the path you need to follow
to get uh through uh the machine
the zeros are the places where you don't
go
um
okay so the output label here
the the output is going to be the label
of the one
output node
whatever you're labeling that because if
it's a one that means the path went to
the one and if it's a zero that means
the path didn't go to the one who went
to the zero
okay so just by looking at this value
you can see what the output of the
machine is
all right so
um
let's
describe a different way of defining
this labeling without just looking at
the path
but it's going to capture exactly the
same thing
um
so we're going to say
whenever you have
you know if if you've already labeled a
node
i'll tell you how to label the two edges
that emanate from that node
um
[Music]
i'm going to label the one edge
a and
the query variable
why is that
well
a is going to be either a zero or a one
and it's going to tell us whether or not
the path
entered that node
so if it's a 1 it entered that node at 0
it didn't enter that node the only way
it's going to go down that this branch
here
is if it did enter
the x i node if it didn't enter the x i
know there's no way it can go down this
this branch so we're going to and that
value
so it's so the only way you can go down
this branch is if it went through that
node so that's the a the value of a
and
the x i is a one that's why we say a and
x i so you really have to understand
this little expression here in order you
don't understand that
you're toast
okay so you better understand this so we
can move forward i'm happy to take a
question these are the simplest
questions or sometimes the most valuable
if you understand why i'm labeling it
this way shoot me a chat
um
okay now the other brand uh other branch
i'm going to say well i'm only going to
go down this edge
if well a is true so i did go through
that node
and
x i is false so this is going to be a
and the complement of x i
all right so that's how i'm going to
label these this is another way
giving these expressions for labeling
these edges
based on the label of that node and
similarly in order to complete the
picture i've got to tell you how to
label the nodes based on the edges that
are coming into it
so if i know that i have a1 a2 and a3
which tell me
the status in terms of the path of
whether the path
went through any of these edges
well i know that it's going to go to
that node if it went it's the or of
these values
if the path went through here or it went
through there or went through there then
it's going to go through that note
that's why the or is the right thing to
say
so this gives me another way of
constructing the labeling over here
without even talking about paths
but i'm just as i describe it i argue
that it's going to get the same result
all right
so there's a question can we quickly say
again why we can't do that on boolean
i'm not sure i understand the question
so please send it to me again but this
is right now everything is boolean we
haven't done arithmetically anything yet
um
and the reason why we can't just live in
the boolean world is that
you know just by taking boolean values
of boolean assignments here we don't
have a high enough probability of
catching a difference between the two
machines
all right so let's continue um
all right so now i'm going to talk about
how to we're going to extend this
to the non-boolean case
okay using the arithmetic
arithmetization method so first of all
arithmetization is a simulation of and
and or with plus and times
such that if i think about
um
[Music]
true as a one and false as a zero
this is going to give me a faithful
simulation it's going to do the right
thing um it's going to compute exactly
the same values that we expect
so like a and b
well
um
times works just like and
um
and um right you know it does for
for one and zero
as true and false times exactly works
like and
um
and
negation is one minus
and or is going to be the sum
minus the product
and then these just give you the right
values
um a a or b
if you just calculate it out
by plugging in ones or zeros you get the
right answer just by using using this
arithmetic
um
so
now what we're going to do
instead of using the boolean labeling
we'll just use the arithmetical labeling
but it's going to compute exactly the
same thing because the arithmetic
simulates the boolean
um
so uh we always go through the start
nodes so there's no question about
labeling the very start node with a one
but now i'm going to give expressions
just like the boolean expressions but
now they're going to use plus and times
instead of ands and ors um
so let's just see remember what we
defined before we had a and
x i for this edge
i'm going to replace that what is and we
just look up here in our table in our in
our translation table
and becomes times
so we're going to replace that with a
times x i
and it's going to work exactly the same
but you know the difference is that
this makes sense
even when we have non-boolean values
times and plus are defined
for non-boolean values
um
where zans and or not
so what what goes down on this edge um
well this was
a and the complement of x i as you
remember
uh so we're going to that's going to
become a times 1 minus x i
and then similarly
we had or over here and here's a little
bit of a trick but that's going to be
important for the for the for the
analysis that we're going to do
instead of using the recipe for um or
in terms of plus and times we're going
to have something a little simpler it's
just going to be the song
and the reason why that works it's good
to understand
is that
because of the acyclic nature of the
branching programs at most one of these
edges can have a path through it
so this is a kind of very special ore
um
sometimes called a disjoint or
you're not allowed to have more than one
of the values be one because that never
happens in when you have an acyclical
graph you can never have the path coming
down this way and then again coming down
that way then it would be entering that
node twice had to be a cycle
so it's going to be good enough for us
and it necessary for us to represent
uh this or as as a sum
okay
so i think that's all i wanted to say on
this slide um so somebody's asking is a
possible sum of for some of these values
to be negative
yes the values that's a as it stands
right now some of these values can be
negative i haven't put any restriction
on what the values are are going to be
um so the input could be a negative
number and then you're going to just get
negative stuff happening uh in fact
there's negative there's subtractions
going on here so even with positive
numbers i think we did an example last
time i think we're gonna i'm gonna do
that example again uh of exclusive or um
where you're going to you get negative
numbers coming up that doesn't matter
but actually what we're going to end up
doing
is operate doing these calculations
modulo
some prime number q
okay um so i'm going to pick some prime
like
17 and do all the calculations mod 17.
um and the reason for doing it that way
is really because we're going to be
picking random assignments to the um
variables as our input
and it and you need to it makes it makes
the most sense to do that when you have
a finite set of possibilities to pick
them up
um so we're not going to pick like a
random integer there's infinitely many
possibilities and you could yeah you
could set up a distribution there but
that's very complicated that actually
might work i'm not sure i i haven't
actually gone through that analysis but
the typical way people do this is by
looking at what's called a finite field
so i'll talk about that in a second um
why is there at most one one among a1 a2
and a3 so um
the ones i'll say one once again but the
ones correspond to the path so this is a
one if the path went this way
just think about it the path cannot go
through a1 and
can at the same time go through a2
because that means the path went through
this node
then
how is it going to get over to a2 it's
going to go through that node twice
in an acyclic graph you cannot have a
path going through it's the same node
more than once
so you have you're going to have to
think about that
um
okay let's move on
so now we're going to talk about the
same um
uh
we're going to
we're going to look at that
non-boolean labeling applied to an
example so here is a
very simple branching program that
actually computes the exclusive or
function in the boolean world
um
so this is the labeling that we just
i just developed for you the the uh
arithmetical labeling um and we always
label the start node with one because
the path always goes through there um
and now let's look at this before we
jump ahead let's look at this edge here
remember what it is we have to apply
this rule here this is the one edge
coming out of a node that already is
labeled
so it's that that label on that node
times the x i because that if you're
thinking about that's the and captures
the end
so it's just a times x i so xor it's x1
in this case so it's going to be x1 is a
2
in our input
so it's going to be 1 which is the a
times the x one which is two so that's
just this this edge gets labeled two
now this well okay let's look at this
edge now i think that's next
this is the one minus x i it's one minus
x one so it's one minus two so we're
going to end up with a minus one one
minus times minus
one times one minus two which is minus
one so it's a minus one
now we're going to label these two nodes
using the other rule
um
so this gets a 2 because that's the sum
of the incoming edges this gets a minus
1 because that's the sum of its incoming
edges
and now we're going to look at um
uh
which order did i do this in okay it's
going to do this uh
this edge now
um zero edge which is going to be 2
times 1 minus
its variable so it's 1 minus x2 x2 is a
3
so it's 1 minus 3
it's a minus 2 so 2 times minus 2 is
minus 4.
okay i don't want to rush through
there's no point in just blabbering on
i'm just trying to do work this example
so you get the idea
okay so could you fill this out this
next one out yourself
so this is the one outgoing edge from
this x2 node
um so x2 is a x2 is labeled
uh
with two here so there's a is two
this is the one edge going out so it's
the one on this side here so it's
two times the
x2 x2 is a three so it's two times three
so this should be six
oops right here six
i'm gonna do the same thing so
x2 is labeled minus one
um
so minus one times one minus so you got
a two here
you get a minus three here just
following again the same um process
and now let's let's say what is the
label on the zero node here so you again
you take the sum of its incoming labels
so there was a two
and a six
so that's an eight
and this is a
uh
a minus three and a minus four coming in
so it's a minus seven what's the output
the output is minus seven because that's
the label on the one node
okay output is minus seven
okay
so this is going to be our
way of
defining
the
output
of a branching program when it has a
non-boolean setting on its inputs
if you had the boolean setting on its
inputs
and you followed this procedure what
would you get out
you would get the same answer that you
would get by following the path
because the
arithmetical simulation is a faithful
simulation of the ands and ors and the
ends and auras capture exactly when the
what the path does
so this is a strict extension
of the operation of the branching
program into a new realm these
non-boolean values on the old realm it
behaves just as it would or
did originally and that's critical
to understand that
um
yeah somebody's asking would the final
value of the zero state also be the same
sure
in the ba in the in the boolean case
if we follow this in the boolean cases
all of the labels would be exactly what
they were
in the bool you know
you know they would just be the zeros
and ones that we had from before
so does this exactly mimic xor if you
take this all mod
2
hmm
i don't know i'd have to think about
that i don't think that that's essential
um in this case it might behave
correctly if you take the answer mod 2
for xor but the xor is going to be very
special i'm not sure that might happen
to be true i'd have to think about it
for a second but um
i'm not sure that's in
relevant
um
okay this is a good question if i picked
a different branching program that also
implements xor
um so it would be an equivalent
branching program
would it behave the same way
on the non-boolean values
and the answer to that is
yes and no
you understand the question it's a very
good question and it's actually we're
going to prove this
you know
in the analysis
it's going to be easy to prove because i
gave you both possibilities yes and no
but let me tell you what i mean by that
so um so you understand the question
suppose i had a different branching
program i'm not sure you can come up
with a different branching program but
let's make let's let's let's say you
could you have a different branching
program yeah sure you can come you can
do the variables in a different order
for example so you suppose you come up
with a different branching program that
gives you
xor
and now you plugged in
two and three
would i always get the same value out
yes
if that other branching program was read
once
no
not necessarily if it's not read once
and that's why read once is critical
as we will prove
for two read once branching programs if
they behave the same way
on the boolean values
they behave the same way
even on the non-boolean values
that's not necessarily true if the
branching programs are not read once
okay so let's we will see that we will
prove that
and use that that's going to be
important
okay so here is the algorithm sketch
which is kind of a little bit even sort
of suggested by that uh that that
that very good question um
uh
so what we're going to do is we want to
take the um the two branching programs
for with that we're trying to test if
they're equivalent
we're going to pick a random non-boolean
input assignment
so set the values here
chosen from the field but we'll get
there
you know
a random value for x1 a random value for
x2 and so on these could be numbers like
17 and 25 and 23 and so on
and then run
using this process run the branching
programs
to evaluate them on that non-boolean
assignment
if they
disagree then we're going to know that
the two branching programs were not
equivalent even on the non-boolean case
even on the bullying case did i say that
wrong so if they disagree even on the
non-bullying case they have to be an
equivalent even in the boolean case
not obvious
but if they agree
and if they agree
then it's not a guarantee that they're
equivalent but it's going to be very
strong evidence that they're that
they're equivalent
okay so that's where the probabilistic
nature is going to come in
okay so we're going to prove that
so first we have to develop an algebraic
fact
um
and that involves polynomials
this is this is a simple thing that i
think many of you have run into already
perhaps even you know in high school um
uh i'm not going to prove the algebraic
facts but i'm going to state them and
actually the proofs are not hard they're
in the textbook um
okay so let's suppose we have a
polynomial
of degree d here it happens to have b so
you know some kind there's a bunch of
constants these a's are constants
x is the variable of the polynomial
and uni i presume you've seen
polynomials written out like this
and so if you have if you assign x to
some value some constant value z
um
and the polynomial value evaluates to
zero
we often call that a root of the
polynomial
um so the polynomial these are the
places where the polynomial evaluates to
zero and i've kind of shown over here
those are the roots
it's not hard to show
that a low degree polynomial cannot have
lots of roots
basically if the polynomial has degree
at most d it can have at most d roots as
long as the polynomial itself is not the
everywhere zero
polynomial because obviously then
everything is a root
oops typo thank you should be d minus
two over there
uh
pretend that's a two
uh
all right so um
all right so if we have a low degree
polynomial let's not get ahead of
ourselves below degree polynomial uh
degree did you do the polynomial of
degree of most d it has the most d roots
and that's a simple proof um the basic
idea is every time you have a if you
have a root of the polynomial you know
so if um
uh
if setting x equal to five
gives you a root of the polynomial um
you know it's a zero of the polynomial
then x you can easily see that x minus
five is a factor of the polynomial you
can divide out x minus you can divide
out
by x you can divide by x minus five and
you get a new polynomial of degree one
less
and you can just uh which is going by by
induction has a one fewer uh root um so
you can just divide out by the roots
basically it's very straightforward
uh
um
uh
okay so now um other very important
thing
uh
if i have two polynomials
that are both low degree they cannot
agree
on very many places
that follows right
from the from what i just proved above
because what i'll do is i take those two
polynomials and i look at the difference
which is also a low degree polynomial
every time there's an agreement between
those two original polynomials there's a
zero of the difference polynomial
and because that difference polynomial
cannot have too many zeros the two
original polynomials cannot have too
many agreements
okay
so the corollary is that if x and y are
both polynomials of degree of most d
and they're not the same polynomial
because then the difference would be the
zero polynomial
then the number of places where they
equal is the most d
okay so the proof is just letting p be
the difference of p one and p two
very standard kind of a trick
okay now the the above is going to hold
for any field so we're gonna be a field
is just a set with plus and times with
the familiar
um properties
the distributive law and so on and
identities and all the stuff that you
would expect plus some time to have in
in the normal world
um and so we're going to talk about
finite field
that has only q elements
um
that has exactly two elements where q is
a prime number so it turns out and i'm
not going to prove all this but it's
pretty simple stuff
that if you just take the numbers from
one to q minus one
from zero to q minus one um they uh and
use plus and times mod q
that that does has all the right
properties to be a field
okay so we just think of it it's just
modular arithmetic
mod some prime q
okay and then it's we can in a natural
way pick
a random
assignment
to
a variable from the field because it's
just choosing from among queue
possibilities
so uh
uh
yeah so the
yeah so getting a question here the the
the the coefficients of the polynomial
and the assignment to the variables
they're all going to come from this
field
so everything's going to be we're all
going everything is going to be
operating uh
in this field don't get don't let that
throw you off or you're just your
ordinary intuition about the way
arithmetic works is going to be just
fine
um
okay
now
if we have
ah but this is important here from the
perspective of thinking about this
probabilistically so i'm going to
rethink about this polynomial lemma
which says there are not too many
roots
um in terms of the probability of
picking an element of the field what are
the changes that it happens to be a root
so if you have a low degree polynomial
and you pick a random value in the field
what's the probability that you got a
root
well it's just the number of roots
divided by the size of the field
so if you have this really big field and
you have this low degree polynomial it's
going to be pretty unlikely that that
you're going to end up picking one of
the zeros
one of the roots
uh just at random
that's all that's this is saying
so there's the most d roots out of the q
possibilities
and the last thing i'm going to
introduce here is the multivariable
version of this
um which is called
perhaps somewhat unfairly but uh it's
called the schwarz zipple lemma
though in various forms it had been um
known
prior to their work um
in some cases
you know the literature actually goes
back
a long ways but anyway the
this is called the short zipline it
doesn't really matter um uh
except to the people whose
um
uh
credit is being denied but
that's not one of us uh so anyway the
schwarzepilema
says that if you have now a polynomial
in several variables which is not the
zero polynomial
where each variable has low degree so if
i say if has degree at most d in each x
i
so each variable is going to have at
most an exponent of d appearing in that
polynomial
and now if we pick
random values
to assign to all of those m variables
from the field
the proper probability that we ended up
with a root
and we ended up with a zero
is something you can bound
so it's m times d so the number of
variables times this maximum degree
divided by the size of the field
and this is going to come up later for
us
and this is another
fairly simple proof
a little bit more sophisticated than the
one that we had above and in fact she
uses that one as a um
as a lemma to prove this theorem
okay so we're going to uh not going to
prove any of that but i refer you to the
book if you're curious
um
uh
so
um
yeah so like a couple of good questions
here
what happens if these values are bigger
than q for example then then then it's
not telling you anything if d is bigger
than q m is bigger than q or the product
is bigger than q
then
then you learn nothing
uh from this lemma from this theorem
so
typically what the in applications
you're going to pick a larger you're
going to have the flexibility you get to
choose q to be in something that you
want so we're going to pick the field to
be big enough
so that the m and the so the m and d are
going to be relatively small
um in fact d is going to end up being
one as we will see
um and m is the number of variables so
we're going to pick q which is going to
be substantially larger than the number
of variables
and how is the degree defined in
multi-variable polynomials you know the
m if the polynomial has
you know
x y squared plus
3 x to the fifth y squared z you just
you just pull out each variable
separately
and you look at the maximum degree of
that variable so the x in that case had
had a degree five
appearance the y had a degree two
appearance so you take the maximum over
all of the variables of the degree of
that variable and that's going to be the
bound on the degree of the polynomial
polynomial
so in fact in our case d is going to be
1.
so all of the variable there's not going
to be any exponents on anything
everything's going to be exponent one
um
so q
is is q related to the number we choose
for the mod yeah q is the number we're
choosing for the mod
we're doing everything mod q
so all of the arithmet all the
arithmetic is going to operate mod q
and that's the size of the field
that we're going to pick
okay so i think we're here at the break
um happy to take some more questions um
but why don't we just start that off
uh
and uh
i will see you in five minutes but in
the meantime happy to shoot me questions
okay so what happens if we use boolean
assignments in the xor example
um
so the x you know would that work
um to be able to check
uh uh agreement
um
it would it was so it's hard to it's
hard to
make an argument based on just a single
example
i think the better thing would be
to look at
you know two um
um
branching programs that just differ in a
single place so i can even suggest to
you can make a branching program that
always outputs um
true
it doesn't even read its variables or if
it reads them and they always go to the
same place and then ends up always at
the one output so imagine a branching
program that always outputs one no
matter what the assignments to the
variables are and you can you can easily
make such a thing
and then you make another branching
program that computes the or function
so it reads every variable
and
it's going to be
1 if any one of those variables is set
to 1.
okay so
the only time the or function is 0 is if
everything is set to zero
but
now if you're trying to randomly check
whether the always one function
is equal to the or function
of course without knowing in advance
what they are because that's cheating
you're just given these two functions
and you want to know these two branching
programs
and you want to know are they computing
the same thing or not
and by this procedure of randomly
sampling
there you're always going to get these
branching programs both to say one
unless you just happen to pick the
random assignment of everything set to
zero
and that's very unlikely that you're
gonna pick that you know if you imagine
you have your branching program has a
hundred variables in it it's only two to
the minus 100 chance that you're going
to set them all to zero
randomly
and so you're almost you go you're
extremely unlikely to find the one place
of difference if there's only a single
place if there's lots of places of
difference then you
you know it's not not so bad but if the
number the fraction of differences is
low
you're going to have to do a lot of
samples in order to find that it won't
be in you know possibly exponentially
many samples and then you won't run a
polynomial time okay so let me just see
if there's other questions here um
why can we accept
going back to the boolean labeling side
why can we accept that b1 equals b2 if
b1 and b2 agree on
only on just one input assignment no we
didn't say that
um all right i'll go back there boolean
assignment
is this i'm not sure which one you mean
is this one what do you mean
i don't know
boolean labeling site must be it
why do we
non-boolean labeling okay
so what
no
i see what you're saying you're saying
about this here we're just going to pick
one random assignment
and if they agree on that one random
case
then we will say um accept
because you might think well we should
take to a whole bunch of samples that's
a good question
um but in fact we're going to arrange
the probability such that if the two
things are not equivalent
then you're
it's going to be uh diff the value the
values will be different almost
everywhere a large number of places so
just picking one and having them agree
is going to be strong enough evidence
that you're still going to accept and
you'll have a still a low probability of
getting an error
you'd have to see the analysis
um
are we assuming the roots of the
polynomials are integers no
don't forget when operating over a field
here so it's not even talking about
integers doesn't totally make sense but
it doesn't really matter um we're not
assuming that the bound still
uh
the bounds still oh i should have taken
this away um
the bound still works
um uh
the bound still works
even even if we have non-integers
okay i'm not sure if i'm being helpful
here why don't we just move on
um but we're not assuming that these are
integers because the bound doesn't
doesn't matter if
it says there's at most five roots
including the reals there's still going
to be five roots including the integers
all right so let's continue
um
[Music]
good
all right
so now
everybody's back i hope
let's talk about
moving forward here
um we want to basically what where we're
going with this is we want to
analyze
the algorithm
which picks a random non-boolean input
and evaluates the two branching programs
and in order to do that
we're going to look a little bit more
carefully
at the what happens
uh when we
arithmetize the branching program
and um we run it on these non-boolean
values and so what i'm going to do
is
take these take this branching program
let's say this is the same
xor exclusive or branching program but
instead of
labeling it
as we did before by setting x1 to 2 and
x2 to 3
i'm going to leave x1 and x2 variables
and just do a symbolic execution
so i'm going to label these things
just leaving x1 and x2 as variables
okay so let's just see what we get if we
do that
so
remember we assigned this to be one
now
this edge here
is
you know here's the rule it's a which is
1
times
x1 so this should be
without knowing what the value of x1 is
leaving it as a variable we're just
going to put down x1 over here
over here what goes over there
well it's 1 times 1 minus x1
just 1 minus x1
now we're going to add things up as we
did before
and now what happens for example i think
i have this edge coming next let's look
at this edge the one edge coming out
so that's the label now is x1 on this
node
and the out this is the edge this is the
one edge coming out so you multiply by
the um by the value of x2 that we're
leaving it as a variable so you're just
going to multiply it by x2 and so we're
just going to get x1 times x2
x1 x2
on this edge now what happens on this
edge
so this x1 times think with me
um
times
1 minus x2
and similarly over here we have 1 minus
x1 on this node
so i think on this
on the one edge coming out it's 1 minus
x1 now times x2
because that's this rule again
1 minus x1 times x2 and this is going to
be 1 minus x1 times 1 minus x2
now we're going to add this up
for the zero
node
so we have this this value 1 minus x1 1
minus x2 plus x1 x2
and on this node here we're going to um
add these two values up
so 1 minus x1 times x2 plus x1 times 1
minus x2 and that's the output now
expressed symbolically
now you could plug things in and you're
going to get the same value out as you
did before
um
but let's leave it as a polynomial
for now uh because that's going to um
[Music]
help us and analyze this
so now notice the form of this
polynomial is something special
um
what happens is it's gonna look like a
bunch of products
of
x i's and one minus x i's
added up so it's a sum of products of
that form
so each row here is a product
of x i's and one minus x i's
and then those rows are all added
together
i claim that's going to be the form
of this polynomial you see this already
has that form
um
and the reason for that is
every time
you go to a node you're just adding
things up so that's just going to be
like adding adding up more rows
and every time you go down to through an
edge you're multiplying what you have so
far either by
an x i or a one minus x i
so you're just accumulating products of
x i's and one minus x i's and you're
just adding them up so this is what that
polynomial is going to look like
okay
now let's look a little bit more
carefully
at
the form of this
so for one thing
could we have
um
higher powers here
like a x2 cubed
could that happen
so because you know when i say it's
products of x i's and one minus x i's
maybe there's going to be some x xi's
that appear several times in the product
well that cannot happen
why
read one sprint it's a read once
branching program
so every time you multiply by an x i
or one minus x i
you're never going to do that again
because
doing that would imply you're querying
that variable more than once
so this can't happen
okay so i crossed that and this is sort
of appeared off to the side here but
yeah i'm crossing that out that does not
happen
another thing
that
is part of that's worthy
that's going to be helpful to to notice
about this
this polynomial and by the way maybe i'm
i'm being confusing here this is i'm
supposed to be
representing sort of as a generic form
of the polynomial this is not some
particularly i shouldn't have said this
at the beginning this is not some
particular polynomial that came from
anything i'm just trying to describe
what the general form of the polynomial
looks like
just as an illustration
so you know it's so this polynomial is 1
minus x1 times x2 times 1 minus x3 times
x4
and so on
and and adding up a bunch of rows like
this i'm just saying this is what the
polynomial will look like
for maybe some branching program so
every branching programs that are going
to have some polynomial that looks sort
of like this
um
and what i'm also going to say
what for convenience now i want to say
that each row is going to have every
single variable up here
either as an
x i or as a 1 minus x i
so in order to get that i need to make a
further minor assumption about the
branching program that it's a read
exactly once
currently when i say read once it can it
can avoid reading some variables on some
branches because i could read it most
once but now i want to say that every
variable gets read exactly one time on
every branch
and what that's going to mean is that
every row is going to contain every
variable
either
as an x i or as a 1 minus x i
we can eliminate that extra assumption
easily and i'm going to leave that as an
exercise to you it's not very hard to do
um so i think if you follow me you can
see
and you play with it for a minute or two
you'll see that it doesn't really matter
uh you can either you
but i think just for the for the first
time through this
let's assume that every row has every
variable
okay so important to understand um
okay so
so the this is the output polynomial of
this branching program so
let's look further more at this
polynomial
and understand
the rows
let's take one one row
out of this polynomial
and to understand its um
uh
um
understand what it represents
so one row here it's a product of a
bunch of things
part of a bunch of variables either
variables or one minus the variables
now
notice
let's think about this in the boolean
setting first of all
so in the boolean setting
each of these variables are going to be
zeros and ones
and the one minus the variables are also
going to be zeros and ones so it's going
to be a product of zeros and ones
if there's a zero that appears in that
product
that product is going to be a zero
because zero times anything is a zero
so the only way that product cannot be
um zero
is if all of those
uh
values are once in the boolean case
so
uh that means that
x1
well let's
let's let let's look at the second row
so x1 had to be a one x2 had to be a one
x3 had to be a one x4 had to be a zero
um in order to continue the product of
ones
and so
on
so in fact there's only a single boolean
assignment
to these variables which make that row
one
every other assignment to those
variables makes that row zero
saying that another way
these row each of these rows corresponds
to one of the rows
of the
truth table for the boolean function
where
where the truth table is true gives a
true value gives a one value for the
function on that row
okay so i i hope you've all familiar
with the notion of a truth table of a
boolean function you just write down the
boolean function
every possible assignment to the boolean
function and you write down
one or zero or true or false for what
the value of that function is so just a
tabular representation of the boolean
function it's called the truth table
this thing here gives you all of the
ones all of the rows that are one in
that boolean function that's what this
polynomial gives you
okay so i think we're
at a pause point
for
um this slide and i
um
it's deathly silent on the chat
so i was feeling that that was a
that went down that went down rough
uh for for you um it's it's we're gonna
it's important to understand the form of
this polynomial
uh
here um
you know that it's corresponds to the
truth table of the boolean function so
each one of these rows is only going to
be on again thinking boolean now
each one of these rows is only going to
be one
on that on an assignment which makes the
function one
um
one of the one of the assignments that
makes the function one
okay and somebody says and similarly for
the expression for the zero node yeah
the zero node which i'm not focusing on
but yeah the zero node would be all of
the false rows of the truth table
but the one node the polynomial for the
one node are all of the true rows
correspond to all of the true rows in
the in the in the um
in the um
uh
in the
in the
function of the branching the function
that branching program computes now
the reason why this is let me just tell
you where we're going
is it possible to have two rows that are
the same
if you think about how the rows are
being produced
no you can't have two rows of that are
going to be the same um
uh
because for one thing
you have to think about what what this
looks like when the boolean case if you
have two rows of the same that means
this thing is going to have an output
which is non-boolean
um
because you're going to end up with a 2
coming out that way
by adding those rows together
they can never happen and if you just
look at the way it's constructed you're
never going to because every time you
have a branching
you know one way is a an x one an x i
the other one is one minus x side so
every time you're branching there every
not every time there's a node they're
different um so you're never going to
have two rows that are going to be the
same but
let me tell you the importance of
connecting up
the this polynomial with the truth table
um because that tells us
that if the two functions of the two
branching programs that we started off
with
agree in their boolean values
then the two polynomials are going to be
the same
um
[Music]
you know because if the two branching
programs
uh have the same
boolean function so they're equivalent
then the um
truth tables will be the same and
therefore these polynomials will be the
same
so that and therefore they will behave
the same way on all
non-boolean values because they're the
same polynomial
so i'm sort of getting ahead of myself
but that's where that's what we're going
to argue that's why it's important to
understand the connection with the truth
table
because it sort of builds on the
um
under you know understanding something
about how this thing behaves in the
boolean case is going to give us
information about how it behaves in the
non-boolean case
okay
let's continue here then
um
okay so this is i think is this my
um
yeah this is essentially the last slide
okay um
we're going to spend some time on this
one so here's the algorithm
we are going to take our two branching
programs
the variables are x1 to xm
first of all we're going to find a prime
which is at least
three times
m the number of variables
m is not a very big number
um it's just a number of variables so
finding a prime that's bigger than that
is straightforward we're not talking
about huge primes here we're talking
very modest size primes so you can just
you know just try them
even trial and error is going to be good
enough um
now
that's going to be the
the size of the field it's going to be
field of size q um
and now we're going to pick
a non-boolean assignment to the
variables
and
okay we're going to pick a non-boolean
assignment to the variables
and
[Music]
evaluate the two branching programs on
that non-boolean assignment using the
arithmetization
if they agree
then we'll accept if they don't agree
then we're going to reject
okay now we have to argue that this
works
so we're going to first of all
arithmetize these two branching programs
i'm going to get the two polynomials
they each have the form that as i
described
um so a bunch of rows that correspond to
the truth tables of those two respective
branching programs
okay first claim
that if the branching programs were
equivalent so they compute the same
boolean function
then
the two polynomials agree everywhere
um
so then the two branching programs are
going to get the same value
um
on every non-boolean case as well as on
the boolean cases so they agree on the
boolean that means they always agree
even on the non-bully and i kind of
argue that already
but okay the other point is that if the
two branching programs
are not equivalent so they
differ
at some boolean value
now picking a random value to eval for
the polynomial evaluation you're going
to have only a one-third chance that
they're going to agree
so a small chance
all right so now um
let's prove these two facts the first
one i already kind of argued if the two
branching programs agree on all the
boolean values
um
then their functions have the same truth
table
so then the polynomials are identical
because the polynomials correspond to
the truth table
and so therefore they always agree
even on the non-boolean values
okay so
that means that the probability that if
you evaluate the two polynomials on a
random place
the it's good
whether you'll be equal that's a
certainty
because in fact in this case p1 and p2
are the same polynomial
now for two
if the
branching programs differ somewhere even
in one place
well you know the polynomials could not
be the same
they have to be different polynomials
because the polynomials include the
behavior of the
in the boolean case as well as all the
breadth of the field
um
so the polynomials have to be the same
and now we're going to apply the short
zipple lemma
we have two
different polynomials
they can only agree in a relatively
small number of places
so that says that
from the short simple theorem then um
the probability that p1 and p2 agree at
this random location is at most this
value that we had from before
the degree times the number of variables
divided by the size of the field
the degree is one
and the field is at least three times
uh the number of variables in size so
that means um
you get this inequality here and so
therefore the probability is it is a
third
and most a third
and that's good enough
um this is the probability that you get
the wrong answer it's going to be at
most one-third
so you're going to get the right answer
with at least two-thirds probability so
even just doing a single sample point is
going to be enough to to give a bpp
algorithm
all right so that's
um
what i have is are a couple of check-ins
here
uh now for you
um
[Music]
whoops
somehow this
better take me out of here um
uh
all right
so this is this is a little hard but
let's see how you do on it
suppose the branching program is
uh
well maybe i sort of a little bit
discussed this already that's okay the
branching problems will not read once
the polynomials might have exponents
bigger than one so where would the proof
fail
um would they fail the point where
b1 and b equivalent to b2 implies that
they agree on all boolean inputs so
that's sort of this
um the first step here
or
um
is it that agreeing on all boolean
inputs implies that the polynomials are
the same
or would it be that having the two
polynomials being equal implies that
they always agree
so those are the three sort of steps in
the
part one of the the proof of part one
so let's see uh what do you think there
in a couple questions about picking the
prime number
um
the this uh the prime number here is uh
it's this is a very small prime number
um
you could even represent that prime
prime number in unary
within the amount of time we have
because don't forget this is a prime
number whose magnitude
it is at most the number of variables so
you can write that prime number in unary
and um
uh
finding the prime and testing primality
of testing whether the number is prime
is something that you can do even with
this brute force algorithm
and it would be good enough
um so there's not there's no you don't
have to do anything fancy about testing
primality um in this case
okay so why does it have to be prime
you need it to be prime in order for the
for the um
for it to be a field
so this is just the algebra part
um
if you did not have a prime number then
then some of the field properties don't
work and you may no longer get the um
the fact that the polynomial has a small
number of roots
um
so that
that's all i can say about that is the
polynomial like a hash function for the
branching program are the equal if they
are the same but sometimes the values
also equal if the programs are different
that's an interesting idea so is that
is a polynomial acting like a hash
function i think it's there is something
to what you're saying but i think it's
actually in the other direction um
uh
it's it's actually more it's related to
a hash function but it's actually acting
more like an error correcting code
let's let's save that for later it's a
very good point it's a very good
question maybe we can talk about it
after if you remind me
um
okay let's let's end this poll here
um
should c be
if
having these two agree implies well i
mean
the question is should should we change
p1 and p2 always agree to b1 and b2
always agree well b1 and b2 are behaving
exactly the way b p1 and p2 behave so
i'm not sure it matter really matters
um
uh
too much time on this chat on this poll
here let's end this poll
oh sharing results
um
yes so the correct answer is b
um
that agreeing on all boolean inputs
implies that they're equal
um
the other two are follow kind of
immediately they're still true
but
if it's not read once even though they
agree and all the boolean inputs they
won't necessarily agree
as polynomials
um for one thing like if you just take
the two polynomials
x1 squared and x1
they agree on all the boolean inputs but
they're not the same um
they agree in the boolean world because
zero squared is zero and one squared is
one but they they're not the same
polynomial
okay uh let's move on actually i have
another
uh check in on the same slide here
um
and this is actually answering a
question that we i got in the chat if
p102 where x
you know
how big how big are these polynomials
are they these
look like they could be big if they're
exponentially large would that be a
problem for the time complexity
so
pick a or b
here we're running out of time here so
why don't i uh
not say too much and just let you go
with it
okay
i'm gonna close this down
all in
well
my god
by one point
this is a
this is
uh
this is like georgia here um but do a
recount um
in fact
b was is correct
uh
by it by by a hair here um they are not
polynomial in size the truth tables can
be very large but we don't have to
as we did with the um
branching program for
um
the exclusive or case you don't actually
write down the polynomials to evaluate
them you can evaluate them as you're
going along the polynomials are huge
but you don't have to write down the
polynomials to evaluate them that's only
part of the proof
you don't have to re either the the
algorithm doesn't have to deal with the
polynomials itself
so
maybe a
good uh
good to think about this
that somebody says did i invent this
proof no i did not invent this proof
it's a wonderful proof but it's not mine
i would love to have been get take the
credit for it
okay so um
why don't we uh
wrap this up
so you know can we just is there some
way to simplify the polynomials as we're
going along so that we we don't end up
with them being too big um
and so that we can then just look at the
polynomials not that i know of
um
uh i i i think the polynomials are
really going to be big
and so there's not going to be any way
to um
uh to to view it just as pawn if you
could it would be fantastic because that
would give you a deterministic algorithm
um
i think the only way that people know
how to do this is terms of you know
random inputs the polynomial to a
polynomial which is too big to write
down if you could write it down and just
analyze the polynomials
you'd have a huge huge result there
um
okay
i'm glad
people like this proof that's good
um
how many actual quantities are there in
the formula i'm not sure what that means
what formula
um i mean the polynomial is huge
uh the number of different polynomials
well
i i guess i don't understand the
question what motivates the idea of
arithmetization
what would make somebody think of this
i'm not sure
actually
um
but we're going to use it even in a more
remarkable way
uh in the in the last two lectures of
the course
so stay tuned
i mean this is sort of a clever but
seems very specialized but the um
the next part
where we're going to next application
we're going to use this to analyze
satisfiability which is much more
general kind of a situation and that's
that that i think is especially
remarkable
um
um
for the polynomials
p1 and p2
uh it's only a polynomial number quantum
i don't think so because well it depends
on the size of the field the size of the
no it's going to be something like m to
the n m power right
um so those are the number of possible
inputs
so it's in each each each field element
is
is
has
3m possibilities roughly and there are m
field elements so it's m to the 3m
different possible
inputs
that you're picking at random
so anyway i'm going to shut this down
and move over to the
to the others the office hours zoom
feel free to join me there otherwise i
will see you all on thursday
take care
you